hello reject nation we are going to
watch today from our friend paul
over at heavy spoilers army of the dead
explain the biggest
wtf questions answer time loop robot
zombies ufo
and more a whole bunch of words that i
did not realize were truly associated
with army of the dead my goodness i have
heard there's like crazy theories
through the roof here
a couple of things i wanted to mention
our movie reaction for army of the dead
the reaction highlights is up here on
youtube already there's probably a link
in the description box and pinned
comment full length watch along over at
our patreon
and also um we did do an interview with
paul any kind of an arduous edit because
we would be filming for so long but that
video should be up this weekend
officially so keep a look out for that
last but not least make sure to
subscribe to paul he's almost at 600 000
subscribers make sure to get him there
let's do this guys
[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show my
name's paul and i'm pleased to eat you
you're everyone's dad little details
that hint towards ufos
robot zombies time loops and even the
possibility that van der rohe is
actually
zeus over the weekend i dedicated myself
to unearthing the answers
and after compiling interviews with zack
snyder i've come up with some theories
and answers to the questions that have
no doubt been picking your brains
full spoilers ahead so if you haven't
had a chance to check it out yet then i
recommend that you check out now
drop the thumbs up as that's a
no-brainer and make sure you subscribe
to the channel as this is where i
explain everything from
a to world war z terrible now without
the way thank you that's great
thank you for sticking with me now let's
get into the breakdown of army of the
dead
okay so the movie opens with the
military transporting the alpha zombie
zeus across the desert
this convoy picks the character up from
area 51
which is of course synonymous with
aliens for decades people have theorized
that the secret military base in the
nevada desert was set up after an alien
spaceship crash landed there
and since the 50s there's been a lot of
mystery surrounding the location
extraterrestrials have two been linked
with zombies for a long time
and recently revealed by robert kirkman
that the outbreak in the walking dead
was caused by a space spore that fell to
that said the zombie outbreak may have
been caused by nasa shooting down a
satellite
on its way to venus that's true that's
right yeah that's right
it returned to earth and brought the
dead back to life yes this radiation
could be what kills people upon being
bit and from there it may reanimate
their corpse
much like the two soldiers we meet in
the opening fans have been theorizing
over exactly what's going on with the
virus
and because of the location we can guess
that it was caused by experiments
carried out at area 51.
you can also see two bright white lights
in the sky hovering over the base
and these shoot off as the transport
makes its way out of the area
i heard about it in the comments whoa
first time i've actually
seen it i literally had a thought
process of all right you're reaching
when you said two bright lights i was
like it's probably just and that's the
cloud bam they shut off
a very obvious manner yeah
oh damn it's like alien lights are known
and it's nutty
personally i think that the undead are
actually created through hybrid human
and alien dna
and there is some evidence for this in
the movie when zeus is shot at the end
of the film
within the red blood that squirts from
his head we can also catch flashes of
blue
when the fetus is pulled from zeus's
ghoulfriend if you look closely
you can see that its blood vessels
beneath its skin are glowing blue as
well
whilst zeus and the alphas do look like
your typical zombie
actually think there's more going on
than meets the eye personally i think
that the characters aren't your typical
shamblers
and they're actually living creatures
that just appear to be like the undead
they are gods a new form of human that's
an alien hybrid who's able to reproduce
i believe that the government were
carrying out experiments at area 51
in order to create a new kind of soldier
and after perfecting this they went to
transport zeus across the country to the
next stage
but the vehicle was destroyed and the
alpha was unleashed
martin was then sent in to retrieve the
head of the bride and
using this they'd still be able to carry
on their work
to cover up what happened the government
would then nuke the site
so that all the evidence was buried and
in my opinion if you're looking for what
caused the virus
then it was aliens okay all right you
know that
that was a complaint of ours that you
might see if you watch if you haven't
seen a reaction yet
like in the review part was that we were
annoyed with that trope of like
take the zombies to make an army out of
them find a way to make an army
it's a very tropey thing to do however i
mean this is a well articulated theory
here as to
what's really going on and slowly zach
snyder has been unveiling more
truths behind the scenes of what's
really going on with the zombie world
here so if that
was originally a part of the conception
of creating them by part of the dna
of the design of these alien zombie
creatures then that's not as
it's nowhere near as stupid
if it's like there's some kind of alien
substance here they're experimenting
with
that like yeah i get it yeah it works
that works a lot better now yeah it does
now along with these blue blooded alphas
we can also catch a robot zombie
mikey guzman and after electricity
bursts from its head
we can also see a terminator-esque skull
underneath its skin
when they die they end up roboting which
is like rotten but
with robot and never mind and snyder
recently teased about what was going on
with this
q a session with netflix he indeed
confirmed that our eyes weren't
deceiving us
and that this is in fact a zombie robot
i thought my eyes were deceived
mechanical monsters the director stated
i had the idea from the beginning that
these zombies were going to embody an
evolution
they were on their way to becoming
something else not stagnant like the
zombies were used to
it was a way to make them fresh while
still delivering on the zombie cannon in
some ways
i really wanted this sort of weird
ambiguity to their origins
which of course we'll explore in the
animated series
army of the dead lost vegas without
giving too much away
if you pay close attention there's a
number of zombies that are clearly not
zombies
you see normal zombies and then you see
some robot zombies
are they monitors that the government
has placed among the zombies to monitor
them
are they technology from the other world
what's happening there
so yeah this will be explored in the
upcoming anime
but judging by the last couple of
sentences by snyder
i do think it will be revealed that
their government plans put in to monitor
the situation
but then if they have those why would
they need to make the real thing like
the robots seem way more effective
i know you could program them to do
whatever you want and be
zombies why do you need the one chicken
you literally said everything i was
thinking
but if you could make an airbnb why
aren't you it seems way less risky than
just releasing a bunch of zombies that
kind of can think for themselves and an
answer to some kind of creature you
can't control
what's phase two of that that's a weird
thing
if the government did create them but i
couldn't quite tell from zack snyder's
quote if he was saying these zombies had
evolved to the point where
they were able to they were creating
zombies of their own robot variety
well yeah i mean as the movie progresses
becomes apparent early on that they're
not just typical zombies that they are
intelligence of their own that they can
think and create and feel
so perform medical procedurally
to building cyborgs
that's the benefits of getting alien dna
is you have so much knowledge at your
disposal
like i like the confirmation because
when it happened when we were watching i
was like is that a robot oh no i must
just be the blood and then
to get the confirmation about like now
i'm even more confused why do they exist
exactly but hey that's why there's an
animated series the new deadline being
moved up
is a weird one and they could have been
monitoring things from the inside and
moved the missile launch time up
after spying on the group like snyder
says there's a number of them in the
film
i think i also caught one when zeus is
carrying the bride in
you can notice to the left of the screen
which may be indicating that this one is
indeed a government plan to go let me
know if you spotted any others
as i'd love to see if there's more
dotted about the film now as for the
timeline
video absolutely in a recent live stream
with film junkie
he discussed the bodies that the
characters come across in the vault
we can see that they're wearing the same
clothes as the group and it's theorized
actually one infinite loop in which they
are living out the same events
over and over and over there are some
subtle hints that there are several
versions that have already attempted to
take the money
and when the group arrive at the table
in the casino we see some corpses
slumped over it
scott ward asks if those are another set
of blueprints to the safe
and this is confirmed but then sort of
glossed over
so there are at least three versions of
the group that we see in the film
when talking to film junkie snyder said
i'll also say that
like there's a chance i'm not saying
this is 100 true
and in some ways it's not but the group
at the table i mean
it's pretty subtle that's them also at
the table as well
they get farther every time like this is
the time that they made it
so very strange things going on in the
movie and because of the way that the
film is set up
it's almost impossible to fully guess
exactly what's going
on here however it is possible that the
nuke which always ends the situation
carries a lot with it nukes atoms and
the study of them
also tends to lend itself to the
observation of tachyons
which are particles that actually have
the ability to move backwards through
time
snyder played upon this notion in his
film watchmen wow
to that too it is possible that every
time the knee goes off it resets the
situation
and sends the group back to the store
where they make their way through vegas
carrying out slightly different choices
each time there are potentially
thousands of versions of this film that
we haven't seen
and the final one in which everything
goes the way it should is the one that
we witness
i even have a theory that aliens are
pulling the strings in order for the
virus to get further out
and the one situation in which they win
is when van der rohe gets
is safe from the nuke and is then able
to go on to become the omega to zeus's
alpha
now another question that i had and i
know some of you did
is how the hell did van der rohe survive
the nuclear fallout caused by the blast
yes okay hold on let's pause for a
second
i was not expecting it wants to be such
a
scrambled egghead situation
they really threw a ton into this
everything paul's saying it's backed up
with crazy zack snyder quotes
it's funny because when the time loot
thing is brought up in the movie it's
kind of just like a weird joke and this
philosophy guy getting philosophical
yeah yeah yeah and i i i loved it it was
a funny moment then to hear
that it might be of like what's the
point
of the tie bloop exactly because he's
about to go through a theory here
of it it's just sounding like this world
is crazier than i expected it's like the
matrix too
uh reloaded when you find out that like
this is the sixth version of the matrix
we're watching what
yeah yeah but i i gotta say though i
mean of all these random theories it's
perhaps my favorite one
these weird easter eggs thrown in
because i mean it makes me wonder
what the conception of this was was like
and i mean we're gonna see another movie
and an anime series expounding on all
this but like it really seems like they
threw
every possible sci-fi trope into this
movie in hopes of expanding on at least
one or two of them
and it's pretty crazy how for all this
additional world building they have
in mind you got to kind of give the film
credit
for not getting over convoluted and
trying to
really set up this other stuff but just
alluding
enough to it yeah yeah yeah yeah the
point where it doesn't distract and
you're like why did they explain the
time loop thing
yeah they do the whole robot thing who
wanted it they do you know it's pretty
impressive stuff
damn dude this is uh it's blowing my
mind like the time loop thing that's
just so weird and then they can never
they can just make endless remakes of
this movie with a
slightly different ensemble every time
so i guess the the thing according to
plan
is getting vandal out and so that way
maybe he can spread the virus across
earth and not just keep it contained in
vegas
because the aliens can't figure out how
to get out of vegas
how the hell did van der rohe survive
the nuclear fallout caused by the blast
even with the safe offering shelter as
soon as he stepped out into the
wasteland
the radiation would have killed him
within minutes however it is possible
that because he was infected
that he was able to survive this as
we've discussed in the video
radiation could have been crucial to
causing the undead to rise
and thus with the virus flowing through
his veins he may now be immune to the
devastation caused by the nuke
as for boundaries i have seen a lot of
theories suggesting that he might
actually be zeus himself
and the end of the movie might loop
around into him ending up in the
container at the start of the film
now up top i think we should clarify
this and say that vandal and zeus are
played by two totally different actors
the theory states that because zeus has
similar hair to van der rohe when we
first meet him
and he may actually be a version of the
character when the alpha arrives at
vegas
we also see that he's inspired by the
statue of zeus in front of the olympus
casino
now strangely at this point amari
hardwick's name pops in the screen
suggesting that he too could be playing
zeus the alpha and omega typically means
the beginning
and end unless this could be one big
loop in which the alpha creates its
omega
which goes on to create it there's this
idea of birth and resurrection and van
der rohe even hints to this when
discussing the hero's journey
by joseph campbell his almost cyclical
way of telling a story
involves a character traveling into the
abyss or what's referred to as the belly
of the beast
they have a revelation that takes them
on a path of transformation
and van der rohe realizing he's been
bitten could be that moment
and shout outs to flicks in the city for
suggesting that radiation hitting the
safe could have somehow changed and
mutated bandaro
even more and perhaps helped to create a
new kind of zombie
okay wait a minute so
if if the theory goes that he
i want to make sure i'm understanding
this if the theory goes
that van der rohe is zeus and then it
loops back around to the beginning
of the movie but van der rohe's origin
begins
post-destruction of las vegas yeah so
when he's captured
like everything just resets but he
doesn't reset he comes back as zeus
there's something there that just
doesn't line up to me that makes sense
do you kind of get what i'm saying i
don't know if i articulated that well at
all well
i mean we're dealing with a time loop
and you being your own
grandfather you know all that stuff so
it's a little hard to keep track of but
yeah
i feel like there's an attempt here
maybe to make this safe some sort of
mcguffin of sorts and especially going
back to like if the aliens are trying to
reset the time loop or something like
that then how would he be able to make
it out in the first place
i think i'm with you we're both confused
we're both confused i mean there's
something cool about it but there's like
holes in it that i'm not fully getting
or maybe there
aren't holes in the theory and i can't
really get it here i can see the alpha
mega thing where it's like in a weird
way you know one leads to the other but
i don't
see as as easily how he could just be
zeus especially because you look at zeus
his hair is like similar but you could
tell it's a different
guy i mean let's say it's van der rohe
van der rohe comes out and then he's
bitten and then they
capture him and then everything resets
and they're just taking like
wouldn't the government be aware of the
time loop if they're i don't know
okay like like how does it go back to
where vegas is
how is it in the beginning of the movie
where vegas is back to being normal
yeah and then there's an outbreak that
happens yeah how does he leave the
aftermath being completely destroyed
and then the world forgets and there's a
new outbreak yeah and a fresh vegas
honestly i think they're going to make a
sequel and van der rohe is going to be
the reason why the virus gets out of
vegas that's what it is i don't think
it's a freaking time loop but
i can mostly just see that maybe yeah
the radiation combined with
zombie jews made it so that he could get
out that takes a little bit
yeah that makes more sense but i think
it's a setup for a sequel where it's out
of vegas
you never actually see van der rohe get
bitten so there's a lot of things
potentially going on with him
jan also said it's possible that when
van der rohe emerges from the vault
but he's actually in another timeline
where things start all over again
it's quite a cool little fan theory and
i'd definitely love to hear what you
think and if there's any other questions
or thoughts that you have on the film i
think we said it all
i've left this with a greater
appreciation for this movie and also
much greater confusion
i loved it this was yeah this was really
fun subscribe subscribe subscribe to
paul man like he's
he's incredible like this is possibly my
favorite heavy spoilers video i've ever
seen from the guy
wow my mind is so
yeah guys um army of the dead all right
bring on the expanded universe i'm
excited for it
you guys haven't seen our reaction go
ahead check that out keep a lookout for
our interview with
paul it's quite an in-depth one
subscribe click the notification bell
hit that like button last but not least
jason dolan jason my friend
well i'm sorry to say this you might not
be watching this because you're recently
charged with the capital riots
oh boy that was a scary situation for
you to be in no in all seriousness dude
uh
that was not the jason dolan we were
shouting out jason has been editing and
his producer for the channel kazzy
reacts and i want to shout out this
specific channel because cazzy has put
up a movie reaction for
army of the dead it is quite an
enjoyable reaction so please go ahead
check out her channel she's got
a bunch of reactions to movies shows
some trailers as well
they've been killing it working together
and yeah well worth it
to talk to kazzy uh on the phone for
like an hour once and uh she's a
wonderful
very kind-hearted human being and she's
everything that you imagine her to be
from watching your videos just a very
genuine soul and uh jason hopefully they
uh
drop the charges because i know you were
peer pressured